[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information locale voici les titres de
ce lundi 14 mai à 2018 focus sur
l'extraction challenge 2018 ce sera au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
du 24 au 26 mai à des compétitions
nationales de désincarcération et de
secours d'urgence aux personnes menées
par les sapeurs pompiers
couplé à une campagne de prévention pour
tous les organisateurs seront en plateau
emmanuel macron vient de fêter sa
première année de mandat qu'en pensent
les acteurs de la politique yvelinoise
réponse dans quelques instants et puis
nous nous pencherons sur le festival de
cannes tout au long de la semaine
premier rendez vous avec grégory canal
est depuis la croisette ce soir pour
nous parler du travail des exploitants
et des salles des yvelines qui ont fait
le déplacement dans l'actualité
yvelinoise également la mobilisation
d'une partie des agents travaillant dans
les écoles de versa et des agents
versaillais réunis à l'appel du syndicat
autonome fafpt qui souhaitent être
entendues sur ses propositions
concernant la réorganisation du temps de
travail suite aux évolutions et des
rythmes scolaires les cantines ont été
principalement impactée par le mouvement
de ce lundi un mouvement qui pourrait se
poursuivre jusqu'en septembre
on veut travailler à mercredi sur deux
parce que depuis qui a le rythme
scolaire avant quand il n'avait pas le
rythme scolaire ont travaillé fois les
mercredis parce que c'était le but qu'on
travaillait dans les écoles
maintenant comme il y avait clos rythmes
scolaires les centres de loisirs ils
sont dans les écoles on est obligé de
travailler les mercredis alors nous on
ne demande pas de ne pas travailler on a
dit qu'on veut travailler mais on veut
avoir un mercredi sur deux propos
recueillis par nicolas kirillovitch
c'était il ya un an le 14 mai 2010 est
emmanuel macron était investi président
de la république edouard philippe
devenait premier ministre lendemain et
débuter ainsi les chantiers législatifs
à l'assemblée nationale comment est
perçu dans les yvelines cette première
année d'exercice du pouvoir pour en
parler nicolas landry on sort un nicolas
bonsoir wilfried quelles ont été les
principales réformes réalisées déjà
durant cette première année de mandat
par emmanuel macron emmanuel macron à
commencer par réformer le code du
travail par ordonnance
une loi sur la moralisation de la vie
politique ou encore la suppression
progressive de la taxe d'habitation des
mesures déjà emblématique de ce début de
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron je ne
vous cite que ces trois là mais les
réformes sont déjà nombreuses avec des
heures de travail considérable pour les
députés
quand je vais à la rencontre des
citoyens je le redis m'écoutais je suis
vraiment navré de ne pas être
suffisamment sur le terrain en tout cas
autant que je je je le voudrais parce
que nous sommes très sollicités à
l'assemblée avec tous les projets d'eau
qui arrivent et qui sont là pour
effectivement vous finalement vous
changez votre votre vie donc ce que ce
que je retiens de de son action c'est
toutes les réformes struct de structurel
que nous attendions depuis très très
longtemps et qu'il est en train de mener
et ce travail du pouvoir exécutif nous
pouvons le constater à travers les
statistiques de l'assemblée nationale
une cinquantaine de textes promulgués
par le président de la république 83
projet de loi déposé par le gouvernement
dont 34 examiné en procédure accélérée
une assemblée nationale qualifiée d nick
d'inexpérimenté dominé par les cabinets
ministériels par le président de saint
quentin en yvelines jean michel fourgous
il tient néanmoins à saluer à avoir à
attendre les résultats
écoutez le je crois que oui il ya une
volonté quand même de deux de faire
avancer de remettre en cause un certain
nombre de règles qui pénalise le pays
voilà il ya des bonnes choses des moins
bonnes choses et puis surtout sur des
choses qu'on attend pas ce que c'est on
pourra se prononcer que lorsqu'il y aura
des résultats réels et moi je viens du
monde dans l'entreprise on ne connaît
que les résultats les intentions des
déclarations c'est bien mais les choses
en cours c'est bien mais ya que les
résultats toujours chez les républicains
la présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse parle d'un fossé qui se
creuse entre le pouvoir et la vraie vie
fin de citation et du côté des élus de
gauche à présent alors à gauche la
politique du président de la république
est qualifié de libéral la politique
fiscale et critiqué la réforme de la
sncf est contestée avec une inquiétude
grandissante pour le service public on
voit que les profits du cac 40 ont
récupéré on voit que les milliardaires
deux pays ne sont plus imposés à l'impôt
sur la fortune
en revanche sur le terrain que les
petites associations qui avaient besoin
des contrats aidés
quai plusieurs emplois on tape que ceux
qui se battent pour des pans des
services publics la sncf
les maisons de retraite les hôpitaux
n'ont jamais la moindre attention de la
part du gouvernement et au contraire et
l'économie seront sur le dos des plus
faibles
toujours pour enrichir les plus fortunés
le pays et le rythme accéléré des
réformes ne ralentit pas prenons
l'exemple de la révision
constitutionnelle prévue dans les
prochains mois avec notamment la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires et
c'est une réduction très fortement
contestée par un autre yvelinois
d'ailleurs le président du sénat gérard
larcher merci nicolas solidarité à
présent avec le football-club le phénix
de versailles
ils viennent d'afghanistan de côte
d'ivoire ou encore de guinée des
réfugiés réunis sous les couleurs de la
cité royale un groupe de bénévoles les
aides et les soutiennent
pour le premier anniversaire du club une
réunion a eu lieu patrick jacques de
dixmude et manon voir ado sudan et
sénégalais ou afghans les migrants de
versailles et bénévoles se sont
retrouvés pour un après midi festif sur
le stade de jussieu faire du football un
vecteur social d'intégration pour des
migrants avec des histoires parfois
tragiques
c'est ce qu'a réussi le fc phoenix ça
leur permet aussi de penser à autre
chose pendant quelques heures salsa le
permis de se retrouver dans un cadre
différent que le centre ça leur permet
de se de mieux se sentir dans la cité du
coup ils ont un rapport à versets qui
n'en peut plus un peu plus intime un peu
plus précis qui connaissent certains
lieux ils connaissent certaines
personnes et certains du jour ont été
repérés par des clubs c'est pas pour ça
que du coup ils sont sauvés qui vont
avoir leurs papiers etc
mais au moins le temps qu'ils sont ici
leur vie est différente pour le premier
anniversaire du club la plupart des
footballeurs étaient là ceux qui ont
changé de centres d'accueil sont revenus
pour l'occasion j'étais lent ses joueurs
et des là et j'étais très privé à après
taille on nous organiser du match ils
ont de ramener des images et les
aveugles pour les gens là bas au centre
aussi elles ont très bon et parfois ils
on ramène des chaussures des habits
vous partagez les gens vraiment sur
trois jeunes j depuis sa création 130
joueurs âgés de 18 à 55 ans affronte
divers équipe au sein du club
lc phoenix c'est une équipe qui est en
recomposition permanente
nous n'avons pas un noyau dur qui est
sur lequel s'appuyer pendant des mois
parce que beaucoup de joueurs ne
connaissent pas leur avenir ils peuvent
être transférées quasiment du jour au
lendemain
ufc phoenix espère encore de belles
années continuera ses rencontres tous
leurs rendez vous qui sont indiqués sur
leur page facebook
la première édition de la bourse d'été
pour les enfants de coignières à
l'initiative des parents d'élèves les
enfants des groupes scolaires
élémentaires de la commune étaient
invités à venir vendre leurs joies et
leurs vêtements vous le voyez sur ces
images le succès était au rendez-vous
l'opération sera sans doute élargie aux
collégiens l'année prochaine rendez vous
qui a permis de fédérer parents et
enfants écouter les parents se
rencontrent alors la plupart pour le
coup sont de coignières donc on se
connaît tous à peu près maintenant
comment les enfants eux ne se
connaissent pas forcément puisqu'ils
sont des écoles différentes
et du coup ça leur permet de faire
connaissance puis de passer un bon
moment
voilà sous le contrôle des parents c'est
un constat inquiétant on estime que 30 %
des colonies d'abeilles disparaissent
chaque année en cause les pesticides les
maladies mais aussi le manque de
nourriture les fermes de gally se sont
engagés dans leur préservation et ont
organisé la deuxième édition des fêtes
de la fête des abeilles un moment des
changes pour sensibiliser le grand
public avant de retrouver l'un des
responsables des fermes de gally en
plateau le reportage de camille lambert
dans le corps les même alvéole vont
servir à stocker du miel du pollen et à
élever le les abeilles le coût 20 c'est
la première fois que ces visiteurs
découvrent une ruche plus de 40 mille
abeilles vivent à l'intérieur
et si les voir d'aussi prêt peut être
impressionnant les plus jeunes ne
semblent pas effrayer en khl à
petit-mars là et là il a un peu craqué
comme ça la veille
et là on peut manger les mets dans ma
vie le miel mes enfants puissent voir
voilà comment est ce qu'on fait du miel
et comment est-ce que voilà comment est
ce qu'elles vivent comment est ce
qu'elles vivent entraîne dans une ruche
c'est très intéressant pour les enfants
et je pense est très utile effectivement
pour pour parler justement la
préservation des abeilles qu'un sujet
dont on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui les
fermes de gally ont organisé la deuxième
édition de la fête des abeilles
un week-end pour sensibiliser à la
protection de ces insectes indispensable
à notre alimentation
un tiers de leur mortalité est causée
par le manque de nourriture
à force de faire de la surproduction et
de la productivité agricole
on a fini déjà par changer un petit peu
le paysage
elles ont du mal à s'en sortir
puisqu'elle ne trouve pas une diversité
dans leur nourriture
les jolies fleurs qui sent bon et qui en
plus vont leur apporter soit du pollen
c'est à dire des protéines soit du
nectar qu elles transformeront en miel
c'est la première chose pour les
observer pour les voir et pour les
protéger
une colonie d'abeilles est capable de
butiner + 2 4 milliards de fleurs par an
les fermes de gally invite à créer des
garde manger dans son jardin ou sur son
balcon pour les aider à se nourrir selon
la phrase communément
pardon selon la phrase attribuée
communément einstein on va y arriver sûr
mais les mots dans l'ordre sans les
abeilles il ne resterait que peu de
temps à l'homme
bruno gansel bonsoir vous êtes
responsable communication des fermes de
gally
est ce que c'est cette phrase qui vous a
poussé à vous mobiliser justement ce qui
nous a poussés à nous mobiliser ses deux
c'est le constat qu'on fait sur les
populations d'abeilles nous on élève à
gali des abeilles depuis 1986 et on
constate comme bon nombre d'apiculteurs
que chaque année des colonies d'abeilles
disparaissent alors que ces insectes
sont très importants pour assurer de la
pollinisation ce ne sont pas les seuls
les abeilles qui sont dans les ruches
sont dit les abeilles domestiques
il y en a cinq espèces en france mais il
ya plus d'un millier d'espèces
d'abeilles autres dans le pays et tout
ces abeilles sont indispensables aux
agriculteurs à nous qui produisons pour
nourrir la population sans abeilles il
n'y a pas de pollinisation donc pas de
fruits au début les fermes de gally sont
implantés à saint-cyr-l'ecole à
sartrouville également vous avez voulu
montrer que chacun peut se mobiliser et
peut agir aussi exactement nous
on se mobilise en cultivant plusieurs
hectares de plantes mellifères
mais ce qu'on a voulu montrer c'est en
un maximum de gens avec nous dans cette
démarche en distribuant des sachets de
graines de plantes mellifères et est
plein de pollen qui sont facilement ce
meuble chez soi dans une jardinière dans
un massif et qui vont permettre de
nourrir les abeilles quand elles en ont
besoin c'est à dire principalement l'été
et en fin d'été à l'automne
les premières actions qui ont été menées
remonté à 80,6 c'est ça pour les fermes
de gally vous aviez installé des ruches
déjà c'est ça dès 1986 on a installé nos
premiers ruchers
sur la ferme de gally sion affirme de
vaud l'usso en 95 on a ouvert notre
première ruche pédagogique au sein de la
ferme ouverte de gagny et on élève
actuellement une centaine de ruches donc
différent ruche et sur le plein de
versailles
là on parle de vos actions de la
mobilisation du grand public il ya aussi
une enquête qui a mené régulièrement et
encore aujourd'hui exactement on s la
retape emmène une étude depuis un an et
demi avec biodiversité est une start up
belge qui vise à utiliser la bei pour
savoir un petit peu comment dans quel
état se trouve l'environnement qui nous
entoure
puisque les abeilles vont visiter toutes
les fleurs à proximité de la ruche ont
fait des prélèvements à intervalles
réguliers chaque saison et on regarde
dans ces prélèvements quels sont les
pollens est ce qu'il ya des pesticides
est ce qu'il ya des métaux lourds et
donc il ya deux ruches sur les fermes de
gally qui sont étudiées on se rend
compte qu'en terme de pesticides ya pas
de soucis qu'en terme de métaux lourds
ya pas de soucis on avait une faiblesse
de diversité polémique en l'an dernier
en octobre à l'automne 2016
dès l'an dernier dès le printemps on a
cultivé 6 hectares de deux cultures de
plantes mellifères de la phacélie du
sainfoin du sarrasin plein de plein de
plein de plantes qui attirent les
abeilles et à l'octobre en octobre 2007
c'est-à-dire un an après on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait multiplié par deux à
deux et demi la diversité de pollen
qu'on retrouvait dans nos ruches certes
ça peut aller très vite
c'est noël et qui est menée par là par
chacun et aussi notamment par les plus
grands parce que vous avez planté sept
hectares du terrain oui mais on est tout
seul donc on a planté sept hectares de
plantes mellifères on veut implanter 16
hectares cette année et ce qu'on
souhaite faire c'est emmener un maximum
de personnes et en se disant qu'à
100 500 1000 2000 5000 si chacun mais un
petit mètre carré de plantes mellifères
sur son dans son jardin sur sa terrasse
eh bien on va arriver à en semences et
des surfaces très importante et c'est
l'activité de chacun d'entre nous qui
rajoutait bout à bout on va constituer
des surfaces importantes comme on dit
c'est les petits ruisseaux qui font les
grandes rivières
et ça ça s'applique également aux abris
c'est peut-être un marginal mais il faut
enlever aussi peut-être la peur des
abeilles l'était on a peur d'être piqué
et autres ce n'est pas le cas alors on
confond souvent abeilles et guêpes et
c'est l'objectif de journée comme
celle-ci du week-end passé où notre
volonté c'est de sensibiliser les
adultes et les enfants leur faire
découvrir ce que sont les abeilles leur
comportement comment est-ce que
fonctionne une ruche on avait une ruche
géante qui faisait quatre mètres carrés
de mètres de haut dans lesquels on
pouvait rentrer circuler et on a
vraiment une volonté pédagogique pour
arriver à faire comprendre ce que sont
les ce que sont les abeilles sont des
insectes qui nous sont très utiles qui
sont pas agressifs il faut s'en occuper
du mieux possible
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres structures qui
ont pris contact avec vous qui veulent
prendre exemple voir comment vous avez
travaillé suite aux résultats notamment
des du travail qui monnayait de l'anc
est donc on travaille avec un certain
nombre d'acteurs locaux c'est encore un
peu prématuré pour en parler mais oui
cette cette démarche intéresse de plus
en plus de monde et ce sera l'occasion
de revenir en plateau pour en parler
largement avec les ainsi beaucoup bruno
ganz end est repassé sur le plateau
responsable des communications des
fermes de gally on continue à parler
environnement avec une autre opération
renouvelée à villepreux l adoption de
poules par les familles afin de réduire
les déchets alimentaires une réunion a
lieu ce week-end avant l'arrivée des
gallinacés dans leur nouveau foyer afin
de garantir notamment leur santé il faut
savoir que cet animal permet à de manger
jusqu'à 75 kg de déchets alimentaires
par an un geste non négligeable pour la
planète
et puis évidemment il ya tous les les
les les effets comment dire induits qui
sont très sympathiques dans une ville
c'est de créer du lien dans le voisinage
voilà et puis tout un aspect éducatif
vous avez pu remarquer que la plupart
des familles qui étaient là avec de
jeunes enfants
c'est vrai que c'est très
pédagogique quoi de de s'occuper d'une
poule on quitte les yvelines pour un
temps le 71e festival de cannes se
déroule jusqu'au 19 mai et comme chaque
année de nombreuses yvelinois se sont
rendus sur la croisette des
professionnels du cinéma des étudiants
et même des musiciens grégory canale est
descendu dans le sud à leur rencontre
pour échanger avec eux tout au long de
la semaine
premiers échanges ce soir avec notamment
à geel pineau le responsable de la salle
le grenier à sel à trappes
elle les images sont assignés alexis
garneau
[Musique]
le festival de cannes attire chaque
année douze mille professionnels du
cinéma ils sont réalisateurs producteurs
acteurs et même exploitant de salles par
mieux égale pineau le responsable du
grenier à sel de trappes vient depuis
une dizaine d'années sur la croisette
est l'occasion pour lui de faire des
rencontres et de voir des films beaucoup
de films trois à cinq projections par
jour est de dénicher quelques bonnes
idées
[Musique]
et pino vous êtes présents ici à cannes
pour ce festival depuis le dimanche 6
mais dites moi à quoi ressemblent vos
journées sur place en a plusieurs types
de journée puisque les premiers jours
sont consacrés aux rencontres aux
réunions du réseau art et essai donc on
a beaucoup de renaître le général les
réunions des avec toutes les
institutions
on voit beaucoup de films aussi ça c'est
les premiers jours et ensuite le
festival commence il a commencé cette
année le mardi soir s'est décalé par
rapport aux années précédentes
et là maintenant le festival c'est comme
chaque festivalier on essaie d'avoir le
plus de films possible donc on fait
beaucoup là que beaucoup beaucoup la
queue on mange quand on peut on marche
on traverse la ville dans tous les sens
l'intéressent et le but pour pour moi
c'est d'aller voir le maximum de films
de rencontrer aussi maximum de gens et
on est vraiment dans
le monde entier du cinéma est réunie à
cannes en ce moment et c'est le moment
pour rencontrer les distributeurs les
institutions les collègues les réunions
beaucoup ça fait une dizaine d'années
que vous venez ici sur place
en tant que passionné de cinéma de deux
responsables de salles comme le grenier
à sel de trappes pourquoi il faut être
ici pourquoi c'est le lieu où il faut
être
cannes c'est un endroit où il ya
beaucoup de décisions qui sont prises il
ya beaucoup d'annoncés qui sont faites
aussi par par le tas le cnc
les dracs et les distributeurs donc il
ya beaucoup de choses qui êtes si d'ici
qui s'annonce ici et c'est aussi le
moment pour rencontrer les collègues
connaître les problèmes des autres de
savoir quelle solution qu'ils ont
trouvée au problème qu'on peut avoir
nous aussi
et aussi beaucoup voir les films parce
que en tant que programmateur
ça me permet de voir très en avance
certains films qui viendront
certainement certains très très
important pour l'année dernière chose
vous ayez beaucoup vous avez vu beaucoup
de films
ici on va pas vous demander les coups de
coeur il faut il faut digérer tout ça
mais est-ce que ça va vous servir dans
la préparation de la programmation au
grenier à sel peut être des projections
qui seront proposés au grenier à sel
pour moi ça a aimé dans le grenier à sel
attrapez-les programmation très art et
essai et tous les films du festival sont
soirée s'est donc donc
je fais mon choix dedans ça me permet de
les connaître à l'avance de pouvoir en
parler mieux aussi
et ça me permet de savoir de fermer
programme est
de la scène de l'année et de
éventuellement d'anticiper vraiment s'il
ya une animation à faire s'il ya un coup
de coeur s'il ya une année à quelqu'un à
que je peux essayer d'inviter et puis
mon pas se mentir il fait beau ça change
un petit peu de la région parisienne
donc on se ressource aussi pas mal merci
del pino merci
[Musique]
chaque jour coup de projecteur sur un
film financé par la région ile-de-france
d'eads symbole réalisé par le chinois
wang bing fait partie de la sélection
officielle dans la catégorie des séances
spéciales
un documentaire de plus de 8 heures qui
aborde le destin tragique de milliers de
prisonniers morts dans des camps de
rééducation dans le nord de la chine il
ya 60 ans
le film est parti à la rencontre des
survivants
d'autant qu'avec au supérieur chien 178
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui rendez-vous
dès demain pour rencontrer de nouveaux
festivaliers yvelinois
retour dans les yvelines pour la fin de
ce journal avec le challenge et
extraction qui se déroulera au vélodrome
nationale du 24 au 26 mai prochain en
plateau le commandant arnaud wind
bienvenus bonsoir merci le lieutenant
sylvain rose pas bienvenue également et
le capitaine emmanuel vécu bonsoir à
vous pour soir à tous les trois alors en
fait il y a deux événements en un seul
le premier ce sont les challenge
nationaux de secours routier et de
secours d'urgence le second est plus
tournée vers le grand public avec pour
but de réduire l'accidentologie on va
commencer par là peut-être parler
challenge nationaux il existe depuis
1999 et chaque année dans un pays
différent c'est bien ça comment ça
s'organise alors effectivement les
challenges de secours routier existe
depuis 1999
donc ils sont répandus un peu partout
dans le monde il ne s'agit pas d'une
particularité évinoise août une
fantaisie nationale c'est vraiment un
événement qui existent un peu partout
dans le monde qui est très diversifiée
cette année il revient aux yvelines la
charge d'organiser le challenge national
de secours routier et de secours aux
personnes
cet événement nous a été confiée par la
fédération française des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines et nous organisons
avec notre partenaire principal qui est
le groupe onno dans l'organisation sur
les épreuves le grand public pourra y
assister et ce sont des équipes des
sapeurs-pompiers de la france entière
oui on ce sont deux équipes qui viennent
un peu de toute la france mais également
de
de pays étrangers mais je vais laisser
la parole le capitaine vécu qui en
charge donc tout à fait son de les
équipes viennent de 19 départements
différents
plus trois équipes internationales qui
viennent également sur ce challenge
national
il en a également quatorze équipes qui
viennent de départements différents
concernant le challenge de secours
d'urgence aux personnes comment
s'organise la préparation de l'équipe
yvelinoise parce que j'imagine que vous
organisez mais vous avez aussi un esprit
de compétiteur et vous adresse
l'emporter à domicile
t'es bien sûr donc l'équipe
yvelinoise composé de huit personnels
lui sapeurs pompiers s'entraînent
actuellement toutes les semaines depuis
plusieurs mois pour être prêt pour ce
challenge qui se déroule à domicile est
évidemment faire bonne figure et celui
qu'ils l'emportent représentera ensuite
la france tout à falaise et représentera
la france au challenge mondial qui se
déroulera cette année en afrique du sud
il ya une vraie différence de niveau
alors déjà peut-être sein même de la
france ait des différentes organisations
des sapeurs pompiers mais aussi avec le
reste du monde aussi une différence de
niveau ou des techniques différentes
c'est aussi l'occasion d'apprendre des
choses peut-être des charges est
l'objectif principal reste l'échangé au
partage de connaissances et techniques
opérationnelles il a forcément une
différence de deux niveaux il ya surtout
une différence de techniques de façon de
procéder
puisque tous les pays ne procède pas de
la même manière non pas les mêmes
matériels n'ont pas les mêmes structures
hospitalières également et puis à des
colloques qui sont organisées en marge
on va venir sur les animations qui sont
préfet milliards aussi des colloques
pour des échanges sur des moments
sérieux on va dire plusieurs colloques
effectivement de prévu puisque les
véhicules sont de plus en plus sûre mais
malheureusement il a toujours autant de
morts fin au temps mort il ya toujours
trop de morts sur les routes est donc
laissée colloque sont
l'opportunité en fait d'échanger sur des
axes de progrès entre sapeurs pompiers
mais également avec des urgentistes des
médecins des constructeurs automobiles
afin de faire évoluer nos techniques et
de renforcer nos compétences dans
l'intérêt des victimes accidentées
d'avant le disait le grand public pourra
assister à tout ça du 24 au 26 mai au
vélodrome nationale donc à saint quentin
en yvelines et puis ya aussi des
animations qui sont prévus il ya plus de
30 animations organisées 30 près de 30
animation ceux liés à la sécurité
routière afin de sensibiliser le grand
public et les scolaires à la sécurité
routière on aura un bus tonneaux il ya
un seul but au lieu qui existe en europe
il sera présent
qui permet si vous voulez de comprendre
comment sortir d'un bus couchés sur le
flanc
voilà donc des animations avec des
voiture tonneau comment évacuer un bus
en situation d'incendié avec des
lunettes de réalité augmentée donc tout
un tas d'animations vraiment liées à la
sécurité routière pour sensibiliser
surtout les plus jeunes les générations
futures la sécurité routière et vous
nous allons accueillir en partenariat
avec l'éducation nationale près de 2000
élèves sur deux jours qui pourront
participer à l'ensemble de ces ateliers
est de 1000 élèves yvelinois yvelinois
qui vont venir sur le collège
démissionner dunois collèges et lycéens
qui vont venir participer commence pas
seule l'entrée sur le site est ce que
c'est payant c'est gratuit et ça peut
venir sur certains des événements un
trait gratuit libre pour tout le monde
et le samedi on aura une approche plus
sur le handicap les personnes à mobilité
réduite on parle beaucoup des morts sur
la route très peu des blessés et des
blessés graves avec des handicaps lourds
et donc du coup on va vraiment lié la
journée du samedi au handicap
ça serait intéressant pour le public
aussi de se confronter aux personnes en
situation de handicap et de se mettre à
leur place on va faire tout un tas
d'animations a donc pensé réellement
innovant en fait cette approche de la
sécurité routière puisque c'est une
approche qu'on a voulu en fait par le
biais des émotions qui fait appel un peu
aux connaissances de chacun qui oblige à
réfléchir et c'est comme ça en fait que
l'on pense réhausser le niveau 2
de résilience des français par rapport
au domaine de la sécurité c'est aussi un
moyen de garder un échange un lien un
contact pour les sapeurs pompiers avec
le grand public qui sera nombreux
combien de versions nous a chanté dans
plusieurs milieux personnes par jour et
effectivement on va fermer également de
la prévention à sentir le public a plus
l'habitude de la prévention incendie
lio pompiers mais là c'est vraiment plus
liés à la sécurité routière et le public
et il dit noah est très attaché à ces
sapeurs pompiers et nous le rendent bien
donc on va aussi doux se mettre à leur
disposition pour parler de ce sujet très
sérieux
un dernier mot pour faire venir le
public on leur diriez quoi venez tester
et vibrer voilà ce sont les trois mots
clés à retenir merci à tous les trois je
le rappel du 24 au 26 mai s'est ouvert à
tous vous l'avez bien évidemment entendu
et puis à l'actualité 1 de ce challenge
et puis des animations elle sera à
suivre aussi sur notre antenne bien
évidemment merci encore c'est la fin de
ce journal je vous retrouve demain mardi
18 heures pour une nouvelle édition très
belle soirée
[Musique]